it's monday the 18th of october the
prime minister to lead tributes to the
murdered mps to david amos in the
commons as new detail emerges about the
suspect
i'm live in lyon c as sir david's family
remember a strong and courageous man
green team as the duke of cambridge
reveals the first winners of his
environmental prize his father sends a
warning about the planet
if we didn't stop polluting our planet
we would face a very dangerous future
indeed
at least 27 people have been killed
dozens are missing after heavy rain
causes floods in southern india
virtually painless could this be a new
way of getting injections without a
needle we'll speak to the brains behind
it
and after a medical emergency holds play
at newcastle
a call for defibrillators in all
football grounds speaking to the man
behind that
at 9 20.
[Music]
good morning to you as you can see
deputy prime minister is with us this
morning i want to talk about tributes
being paid to the conservative npc david
amis in the house of commons later on
thanks for joining us good morning
how do you remember him
well the last event i did with him was
at conference and he was the most
tenacious animal welfare campaigner he'd
been passing private members bills since
the 80s on looking after animals he was
still doing it very much of the vanguard
of it he was a kind decent man
very much known as sort of mr essex mr
south end but he defied caricature he
was big-hearted
he came down just last month for the
10-year anniversary of my conservative
women's organization event he was
incredibly energetic
but what really defined him is that even
when he disagreed with people there was
a generosity of spirit and
we'll miss him and i'll miss him
personally he was very very kind
generous with his time and advice ever
since i've been in the house of commons
it's not a one-off though is it two mps
in five years what needs to change
well i think the first thing to say is
we've i was contacted by my local police
over the weekend all mps will be getting
those calls just to check in we
appreciate that i certainly found it
reassuring i think everyone's in a
slightly different position everyone's
got different circumstances so i don't
want to sort of speak for others my own
personal feeling is we need to do our
due diligence we need to think about how
available we are and make sure we're not
at undue risk but no one wants and i
certainly don't want a wedge put between
me and the people that elect me and the
people that i'm voted in to serve and i
think a lot of people feel that way so
plain clothes officers at surgeries
well i guess it depends on
the individual i think we're more likely
to look at things like private security
guards there's already i believe uh
money available for that um but again
the problem you've got is a lot of
people coming to see their mp it's quite
a thing to do it takes quite a bit of
courage they'll feel sensitive about it
they'll feel vulnerable itself you do
not want to add to that sense of
foreboding as they're waiting for
example for constituency surgery on the
other hand we are and this is the nature
of the modern age very much out there
we're available we advertise everything
we're doing you know much uh you know
online and all the rest of it um so i
think we need to just think about a
proportionate risk-based approach and
that will vary from person to person i
think the the other thing of course the
elephant in the room and all this is the
amount of online hate uh that we all get
um it's out of control i know the home
secretary has talked to
about what more she wants to do there
the online harms bill is going through
pre-legistered scrutiny um we you know
i'm a free speech man i i want to defend
that
to my dying days but at the same time um
i think the amount of vile abuse and the
vilification directed at mps and in
particular female mps i think it's got
to stop let me take you back if i made
uh deputy prime minister to uh whether
there should be uh plainclothes officers
though do you think there should be or
not i probably wouldn't choose to have
them outside a surgery um that i had i
think uh
i would worry about the chilling effect
i'm not sure it's necessary um to have
that that those members potentially i
suppose women and members of parliament
who wanted them you wouldn't stand in
the way oh come on no no no
look i i think i can't sit here and
legislate or prescribe for every mp i
think anyone that has
a real
nervousness a concern we need to and the
force is already doing this uh the local
force needs to sit down with them and
see what they can do to provide the
concrete security i mean the objective
security but also what will give them
reassurance and peace of mind we're not
going to be much good for our
constituents if we're not confident
going into those meetings
and if we're all looking over our
shoulder with trepidation
i don't know if you've seen i'm sure you
have seen the front page of the times
newspaper this morning um the um qatar
trip last week it was a meeting with the
taliban amongst others
and of course david was was part of that
trip
some of those on the trip feel anxious
about it as a result should they be
offered more security
well i'm going to be very careful what i
say about the case of sir david because
the police need the time and space to
conduct their investigation and i don't
want to say anything that could remotely
be perceived as prejudicing any further
prosecution and but look if anyone is
nervous whether it's from relation to
foreign trips
or the advocacy they do here in the uk
they should talk to their local police
or forces and see what more can be done
there's
a lot of talk uh over the weekend and
also in the newspapers this morning
about post-pandemic radicalism what does
that mean to you
well these terms
people come up with them but i think
what we saw over the period of the
pandemic is a huge amount of additional
activity online um and people using
online whether it's for the work life
balance whether it's for educating their
kids in a way that was uh for the for
the large part was a great relief and a
great solace given what we're all going
through with the pandemic people could
talk to their grandparents their young
children in ways or or or relatives in
ways that we haven't done before but
there is also a dark side uh to what
happens online and i suspect a lot of
people um or or as well as experiencing
the positives there will have been just
moments where people were anxious we
know that um those with mental health uh
struggled during the pandemic and
although crime as a result came down
overall because there less people on the
streets and all the rest of it we know
that there was at least some extra
nefarious activity online so i i
wouldn't want to dub the whole of what
happens online in a negative way it's
hugely emancipating in many ways but i
think in the pandemic it really
magnified the positive but also some of
the vulnerabilities and that's what
we're working through yeah but i mean
there are shadows who are being
radicalized by even bigger shadows
during the pandemic and it seems there's
not much we can do about it well look
there is certainly i think an element of
more people who are at risk vulnerable
or at risk of radicalization would have
been spending more time online i'm
absolutely confident that the
intelligence agencies and the police are
monitoring that with maximum energy and
vigor i know from uh
my time working on the the national
security council as foreign secretary
and and now uh how hard they work but of
course they've got to adapt to a
different set of circumstances uh but
but they're on the case um they do an
incredible job i don't think anyone does
a better job but but what you're really
seeing is behavior morphing um and
changing and obviously we've got to
adapt and and uh respond to that yeah i
suppose what i'm really asking is
whether the prevent programme is still
fit for purpose well prevents much
broader than just the online piece um
look it's being reviewed at the moment
by the home secretary uh this is the
best part three years and that's right
look the what i say more generally about
it it does have the ability to triage up
to what are known as channel panels
which has an interagency input so all
the different arms of government and
local government when there is a
risk-based uh assessment and to take
proportion action in relation to it but
there is never going to be a hundred
percent safety net against those who
wish to harm us what we've got is a
series of mitigations a series of
mitigations and checks to do everything
we can to keep us safe but there is
there is no risk-free society in a in a
free society that where the head of mi5
has consistently over many years being
clear about that
let's talk more about prevent um is it
fit for purpose well look i i don't
think there's ever a perfect
counter extremism strategy so we're
always looking at what we can do to
improve it as i say it's under review
the home secretary's been talking about
that you know when that might um come to
fruition well i'm not sure exactly um
the time frame for it but i know the
home secretary wants to i mean on the
one hand we want to get on with it uh
and learn the lessons from it on the
other hand i think particularly given
what we're going through now and the
questions are being asked i think it's
quite right that it takes into account
any lessons that we that we derive from
the current set of circumstances but you
would think three years is um i mean
it's well overdue
well i think there will be a case for um
setting it out more formally but of
course the reviews that we conduct it's
not like we're waiting till the end of
it to learn the lessons it is an
iterative process um so there's a whole
range of learning that right the way
through gets fed in to what the
obviously the intelligence agencies but
also down at the local authority level
and all the other different arms of
government and indeed the bodies at
local level including people talk about
schools uh what they pick up from local
nhs services so we do learn the lessons
as we go but in terms of coming up with
uh uh a formal uh set of propositions or
or learning uh from it that the home
sector will decide the right moment for
that and obviously we want to take into
account uh everything that we've
learned from the pandemic but also of
course in relation to sir david no
better moment than um the second mp
being murdered in five years well that
will obviously
uh i'm sure crystallize the thinking
around what needs to be done what more
needs to be done but we come back i mean
we've looked at um prevent uh uh for
many years we've we've done lesson
learning uh uh reviews in the past uh
and and what i would say is it's a
process we're always looking to make
sure as the threat evolves we evolve
with it as the nature of the risks we
face change we adapt to it so in a way
it's a process it's not there's not
going to be one silver bullet that comes
out and says okay we're all going to be
perfectly safe we learn the lessons we
build up shore up the defenses and the
mitigations that we can possibly put in
place and we want to do it in a
proportionate way um so i think that's
the right approach
i just wanted to go back briefly if i
may one of the comments that you made
about the pandemic and the lockdown and
it magnifying the vulnerables
does that mean that that potentially
people like you and your colleagues are
more at risk now than they were before
the pandemic
i don't know whether i would say we're
more or less at risk to be honest with
you um since 2010 when i first became an
mp i've been very conscious that the
risk to us as representatives has
increased um i think particularly uh at
the local level i think the from whom
well there's a whole range of things i
think there's um i mean you you
characterize it a certain way i think
there's clearly a lot of people with
mental health issues and the way
mps are out there in the public domain
particularly the amount of abuse we get
they can become a lightning rod for that
who knows whether that has an effect but
i think we're all just conscious that we
as we
try and make sure we've got that
connection of trust with our
constituents and our communities which
most mps across the the divide will all
rally around and want to cherish and
nurture we're all trying to do the best
thing we can for our constituents we
have very different views about it i
think most of us would agree on that we
just don't want that wedge being put in
our way there's been a lot of their
being trust in politicians since the uh
expenses scandal there's other things
that come along indent confidence
there's also the vilification the abuse
we all get and we work very hard to try
and connect uh with our constituents and
our communities and so as we do that of
course there's a risk that comes with it
yeah so we've got to manage that
sensibly okay so how do you manage that
sensory you say you're more vulnerable
now in the last decade than you were
when you first came into parliament
and that can only presumably given the
amount of online hate that we witnessed
in day out that's only going to get
worse
well i think there's no sign that the
abuse is abating but we're going to look
at that very carefully i think it's
incumbent on all of us mps the language
we use the media the language they use
and obviously the social media companies
it's not me passing the back i'm just
saying we've got a collective
responsibility and we've got to look at
the practical measures uh or how we
advertise ourselves it's difficult
because
most constituents don't think about
politics very much every week most
swing voters most of the people who are
hardest to reach most of the vulnerable
we need to really go and advertise
ourselves but by doing that we also
advertise ourselves to everyone else i
think there's a proportionate
approach to this we look at the risk we
talk to our local police forces we
perhaps think about what we do and how
without allowing a wedge to be put in
there between us and our constituents
but also we just i mean this is the
number one thing we do not allow
something like this david amos would be
the first to set to uh to undermine to
corrode or erode our democracy it's
absolutely critical so we'll take the
targeted measures but we don't let the
terrorists uh win by creating wedges or
walls between us and those who go to sin
doesn't help when politicians call each
other things like scum though does it i
think it does but and i know what you're
referring to i think all of us it's
incumbent on all of us i think very
carefully about uh the way we uh
approach politics i always think that
you played the issue not the person uh
used to be said the man uh not the ball
not the man and it's probably a bit
sexist for the current um uh uh
political debate but there is something
in the fact and date and the the the
thing that above all over the weekend
i've been thinking about is there's no
one that epitomized that more than sir
david amos he could break bread with
people from across the aisles he had
very strong views he was catholic or
brexiteer but he never allowed
himself to lose sight and debate of
treating someone else with respect and i
think part of that was the empathy he
had for other people but you acknowledge
that politicians should be perhaps a
little bit more careful about the words
they choose to describe each other we've
been saying it for years um and and and
but i don't what i don't want to do in
the light of david's death is for this
to become uh partisan uh it's incumbent
on all of us it's incumbent on the media
and again i'm not trying to close down
the space for scrutiny of your elected
representatives that's what you're here
for but i think we all need to just
think about are we playing the issue or
are we trying to degrade the individual
because there's been too much of the
latter and you talked about social media
as well um the home secretary talked
about trying to have anonymous accounts
closed down you you second that
well i think we'll look at that what you
don't want to do is either send a
message to to tyrants all over the world
that
that they can expose those who are
campaigning bravely and need that
anonymity equally we know that some of
those campaigning
are vulnerable and will not want to be
in the public domain but i have to say
that on balance i think that there is a
case really for looking very carefully
at this i don't see why people should be
able to abuse the position on social
media
from a from a veil of anonymity
particularly given the consequences that
we're seeing and frankly even short of a
murder i just think and i look at it
from my female colleague's point of view
i know female colleagues of mine i'm
sure it's true across the parties who've
come off twitter because it's just so
vile um i think that can't be right and
i don't think that that is about free
speech i think it is narrowing the
debate for responsible public discourse
we just need to be careful about those
those boundaries okay um
i wondered if i could actually
particularly about what happened with um
sir david on friday um and
we believe that the priest was stopped
from giving him the last rights that
can't be right
i don't know any of the details around
that again i'm being really careful okay
i know i know uh the i i i don't know
anything about it i'm probably just
better off not responding to that
although all i can say is i know how uh
the paramedics on the scene work so hard
to try and keep him alive um so i again
without knowing the full facts forgive
me if i don't jump in and
but you would acknowledge how important
the last rights are to a devout catholic
of course of course i would
let me ask you uh about your comments
about legislating to correct court
judgments in human rights cases that go
against the government
what's the question very happy to do
that so tell me about it why do you feel
that way isn't it up to um judges and
lawyers as opposed to ministers
well there's a whole range of areas
where we get judgments that the
parliament doesn't agree with the
separation of pounds is very clear and i
think this is a criticism of the
judiciary the judiciary would say the
same to me if parliament doesn't like it
vote to correct it and we're looking
very carefully at whether we can
formalize a mechanism or whether we just
do it bit by bit we're um
if it wasn't for the tragic
circumstances i would be presenting a
judicial review and courts bill to the
house of commons today we'll be doing it
later this month one of the things that
we'll look at is
the number of appeals in immigration
tribunal cases and whether after you've
conducted those appeals you can then
even if they've been unsuccessful go and
judicial review in the high court 750 of
those cases a year just three percent of
those are successful seems to me that
that's a good example of litigation by
attrition which is not serving the
public interest
just before i let you go in your old job
uh you were very
much involved with what was happening
with nazin and zagari radcliff she's
lost her latest appeal against a second
jail sentence in iran it would be remiss
of me not to ask you
my heart goes out to nazi and i spoke to
her uh recently um look we are
absolutely clear and i know liz trust uh
and the foreign office team will
continue working uh as tenaciously as
ever to secure her release she's still
uh on furlough my understanding so she's
not in custody um and we call on iran to
release all of our arbitrarily detained
nationals um and uh my heart is with the
family okay we must let you go thank you
thank you
uh
thank
you
reminder if you want to catch up on any
of that interview you can watch it of
course um
on the sky news app or you can head to
my twitter feed to get some
um clips from the interview as well uh
twitter at sky news or at k burley
aisha joining us uh now hello to you
aisha uh the latest from the scene were
there from the deputy prime minister
reluctant to comment on reports that sir
david was
not allowed the la afforded the last
rights ahead of his death on friday
afternoon
yeah well the community here is very
much grieving it's a community in
mourning remembering sir david over the
weekend and early this morning as well
we've seen people come down here to lay
flowers remembering sir david many
messages of support and love for his
friends and family and also people
reflecting on just how much of an impact
and real difference he made on their
lives and of course over the weekend we
also saw vigils take place memorial
services uh people coming together to
really pay tribute to sir david his
family released a statement thanking the
public
for the overwhelming support they
received and in that statement
they described sir david as being a
strong and courageous man they said we
are absolutely broken but we will
survive and carry on for the sake of a
wonderful and inspiring man
okay thank you
looking at some of this morning's
newspapers for you front pages certainly
the eye quotes from the statement
released by sir david amos's family in
which they said
our hearts
are shattered
the daily mail asks why the suspect
wasn't flagged sooner given he was sent
on an anti-terror mentoring
program but that of course was when he
was much younger the police would say
the yorkshire post speaks to kim
ledbetter the sister of the murdered mp
joe cox she now represents the same
constituency and says mps are human
beings too
the song twisted by hate preacher the
son takes a look at the murder suspect
and how he was potentially radicalized
by youtube videos
in other news the guardian hears that a
number of sponsors of the cop 26 climate
summit are unhappy with how it is being
managed and china's testing of a
nuclear-capable hypersonic missile has
alarmed u.s intelligence sources that's
according to the financial times ahead
of cop 26 in glasgow six young climate
activists from six different continents
have delivered a powerful message about
how climate change is already having an
impact on their lives and deliver an
emotive call to action
cop 26 in your hands is a new sky kids
documentary introduced by prince charles
and featuring the prime minister becky
johnson reports
in 2019 experiencing the fires was
pretty scary could there be a more
shocking sight than this
a mosque
now submerged under the rising waters in
the last 20 years we've lost an area of
the amazon that is bigger than the whole
of the united kingdom the reality of
climate change and its impact on lives
around the world
young people on six continents
sharing their experiences
over the last few decades cumbria has
suffered a series of devastating floods
[Music]
their cause close to the heart of prince
charles this his message to them i'm old
enough to have a grandson like you he's
learning how climate change is causing
the big storms
and floods the droughts fires
and food shortages we're seeing around
the world
when i was his age people had no idea
about the damage they were doing but by
the time i was a teenager i started to
see that if we didn't stop polluting our
planet we would face a very dangerous
future indeed
this is why i've spent so much of my
life trying to warn that we have to
operate in ways which make nature thrive
not suffer
as world leaders prepare to meet for cop
26
these young people want action are you
listening are you listening are you
listening
thank you all so much for sharing what
you have to say
your determination to tackle climate
change and your high hopes for cop 26
could be clear if we don't slam on the
brakes right now we're going to go right
past the point
where we're able to use
one new sky documentary cop 26 in your
hands follows six young people from
across the world who are already feeling
the impacts of climate change it's
available now on sky kids or you can
watch it here on sky news at half past
12.
at least 27 people have been reported
killed after the southern indian state
of kerala was hit by flooding neville
lazarus is in delhi for us hi neville
what happened
well these are retreating monsoons they
are not unusual to have rain at this
period of time but it's just the volume
and intensity of the rain in a very
short period of time that has created
havoc in that state there's been floods
there's been landslides a lot of a lot
of people have died because of
landslides and this is
as climate activists has had pointed out
many times over
because of
rapid urbanization and unregulated
development the government report had
mentioned that many years ago but
nothing was done about it because it was
inconvenient
for the government and and development
in in the state of kerala
we've seen flooding in many districts
the indian navy army and the air force
and the disaster risk response teams
have been have been all over the state
trying to rescue people but the problems
are not yet over the meteorological
department has warned of more rain to
come in the next few days fishermen have
been banned from going out into the sea
and the problem is it's going to
increase according to some of the
activists there there have been about
156 relief
centers and camps been set up and
thousands of people evacuated the
problems are still continuing out here
okay thank you
looking at the impacts of climate change
on the planet top line have a look at
our dashboard here we go
so the top line as you know is by now
it's the real-time power mix 42 fossil
fuels being used right now global
warming since 1880 up 1.23 degrees the
next line is how long scientists think
we
probably have left before we reach 1.5
degrees celsius unless something is done
about it at the point of no return say
many and the scary figure at the bottom
the millions of tons in co2 emissions
now it's claims there's no sign of an
end to the volcanic eruption on the
spanish island of la palma four weeks
after it began more than eighteen
hundred buildings and homes have been
destroyed
and around seven thousand people have
been displaced since the volcano first
erupted last month the government's
pledged millions of euros to help
rebuild damaged infrastructure to the
island that lives mainly for tourism
these are live pictures from la palma as
we speak and as you can see no signs
of abating anytime soon
other stories making news for you so far
this morning here on the breakfast show
scotland's coveted passport scheme
begins today amid practical issues and
protests from opposition parties
proof of full vaccination is required to
enter nightclubs and large events in a
bid to limit the spread of the virus and
increased vaccine uptake particularly
among young people
17 people including 16 u.s citizens have
reportedly been kidnapped in haiti it's
thought the missionaries were on their
way home from
building an orphanage when they were
abducted on saturday in the capital of
port-au-prince the u.s state department
says it's in regular contact with senior
haitian authorities to ensure the safety
of its citizens
four men have been arrested following
the death of a man at a lorry park in
felix stowe on sunday
paramedics were called to reports that a
man was in need of urgent medical
attention at around 10 to 2 in the
morning but he was pronounced dead at
the scene police believe the man had
been involved in an argument before his
death
now check out these pictures a rare
water spout has been seen spinning
off the coast of cuba the city's
provincial meteorological center said it
took place around 5 p.m local time
yesterday water spouts are tornadoes
that occur over a body of water but
never reach the land they are
characterized by a funnel-shaped cloud
something like that
still to come on the program for you
fully vaccinated travelers will no
longer need to quarantine from november
the 1st
upon arrival in australia speak to a
local surf school owner on bondi beach
next
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
southeast asia correspondent in bangkok
[Music]
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line they are dying here
[Music]
boy we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us get ready
instructing you to stay at home
i can't believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
[Music]
[Applause]
tributes will be paid to the
conservative mp sir david amos in the
house of commons later politicians are
expected to share their memories of the
father of five who was killed while
meeting constituents in leon c on friday
earlier i asked the justice secretary
and deputy prime minister dominic raab
whether he thinks there should be plain
clothes police officers outside
constituency surgeries
i probably wouldn't choose to have them
outside a surgery um that i had i think
uh
i would worry about the chilling effect
i'm not sure it's necessary um to have
that those members potentially i suppose
women and members of parliament who
wanted them you wouldn't stand in the
way oh no no no no
look i i think i can't sit here and
legislate or prescribe for every mp i
think anyone that has
a real uh nervousness a concern we need
to and the force is already doing this
uh the local force needs to sit down
with them and see what they can do to
provide the concrete security i mean the
objective security but also what will
give them reassurance and peace of mind
we're not going to be much good for our
constituents if we're not confident
going into those meetings
and if we're all looking over our
shoulder with trepidation
tamara is here hi tomorrow good morning
thoughts well you get a sense cave from
dominic rob of why this is such a
difficult issue mps security he said
that his police force had contacted him
over the weekend indeed the home
secretary said that all police forces
should have contacted their mps over the
weekend to review security in the light
of this tragic incident which has really
shocked westminster when i've talked to
mps over the weekend
whatever their political party and
wherever they are in the country they
feel like it could have been me it could
have been anyone and they're very
concerned about it but
when you go into what measures should be
taken should mps stop meeting
constituents in person and do it online
a lot of mps would feel deeply
uncomfortable about that should there be
plainclothes police on the door dominic
raab there said he wouldn't want that he
thinks it would be chilling he
understands why other mps would want to
but should this be for the police to
decide rather than individual mps these
are the sort of difficult distinctions
that need to be made we know that the
speaker of the house of commons and the
home secretary want things to change
immediately right now in terms
in time for the surgeries that are
happening in constituencies next friday
they want this to be action and not
talking but a lot of mps have very
different views on how they want that to
look and as far as the prevent program
is concerned it's um is it fit for
purpose it's been reviewed for the best
part of the last three years what did he
say about that well that is a very
important part of this because um the
reports we've had are that this
suspect was at some point
referred to the prevent program but in
the year to march when he was at school
when he was at school he's now 25. um in
the year to march there were six
thousand referrals to the prevent
program as dominick robb was saying
quoting that the head of mi5 you can't
follow every single one of them no
counter-terrorism system is infallible
but
were there concerns that should have
been escalated up the chain he said that
there is the potential to do that if
someone is on the channel
counter-extremist program there is the
potential for them to be triaged up he
said if there are concerns about them
now we have no idea if that happened in
this situation but he certainly seemed
to be kicking it back to the home office
by saying this prevent review which has
been delayed by covert and delayed by
various other things he says they are
learning lessons all the time but it's
important that all all of the events are
this weekend and what can be learned
from them what seems to many people to
be an entirely random attack or we don't
know at the moment and what else may
have fed into it that all needs to be
learned when it comes to this prevent
review which we still don't have a date
for when it will come back no and and
just finally when it came to a story in
this morning's newspaper suggesting that
potentially
what happened to david could have had a
link with his visit his recent visit to
castro he had a view on that as well
yeah so um so david amos was the chair
of the all-party group there lots of mps
who in groups were interested in certain
countries and he'd been on a trip there
and we have no idea at this stage
whether that was was
feeding into the attack but um when you
put it to him that other people on that
trip may be now concerned about their
security
and that may be something that should be
raised he seemed to to agree that that's
something that should be considered okay
for now tomorrow thank you
uh in other news you'll know of course
half term lots of people are hoping to
be able to travel given that the red
list has got smaller and smaller and
smaller i think only seven countries
remain on the red list most of those in
south america one of the countries that
has come off
is australia and fully vaccinated
travelers able to enter new south wales
from the 1st of november without the
need to self quarantine it's another
major governmental easing of covet
restrictions following sydney's recent
lockdown lift which will open the door
to tourism and business for the holiday
industry joined now by the owner of surf
school let's go surfing brenda miley hi
brenda
hi hi
oh my that looks absolutely
amazing tell me what life is like on
bondi beach today
it's absolutely beautiful it's a
fantastic day and everyone's out having
a great time in this earth so
it's starting to get back to normal and
we're feeling very free
okay what was it like during lockdown
look lockdown was tricky um i actually
still haven't had my hair cut so that's
a bit of a concern
but um
we were all stuck within five kilometers
but i was lucky that i lived on bondi
and we could exercise for one hour a day
so i could go surfing
how how's it impacted on other
businesses uh around the beach and what
difference do you think it will make now
oh look everybody is in a world of pain
um
during lockdown you know we we
it's hard to know what to do how to do
it you know we've lost staff
because they've moved on to other
activities or other jobs so now
lockdown's lifted we're all feeling
really positive and really excited and
looking forward to having people come
visit us again
so what's the appeal of bondi beach tell
us
well you just have to look out there
it's beautiful
um it's
uh
bondo beach is eight kilometers from
australia's largest city sydney but when
you get down on the beach it could be
anywhere in the world so um it's a
beautiful beach
beautiful surf
fun activities
great cafes great places to have a beer
so
we'd love to welcome you all back here
and is there
any concern that this might just be well
it's tentative steps baby steps and you
could find yourselves in a similar
position as we have in the uk a couple
of times where we've had to lock down
again
absolutely look during covert anything
could happen um we're just lucky that we
started to move out of the the big
lockdown
but you know anything could happen and
we could still get locked down again i
feel like the government though has sort
of started moving us along a bit better
so um you know we're all positive and
hoping that it's going to be okay
i'm sure brandon but just before i let
you go what's a normal day for you on
bondi beach just so you can rub it in
even more
well i get up really early like at six
a.m and i come for a jog on the beach or
a surf depending on what the surf's like
um then i go and do some work a bit of
admin in my surf school i might teach
some surfing lessons
then i go for another surf on the beach
um and i have a nice
coffee
and have a nice lunch at the rsl club so
i sort of do what i take people who come
visiting
um with me
oh
yeah i mean that sounds horrible you'd
much prefer my day getting up at 3 17 in
the dark and having a cup of tea and
then getting to the office and reading
the papers trust me
let's let's swap for a week and see how
we get on
oh yeah i'd love to come over definitely
hey fantastic it's a deal it's good to
talk to you thank you so much for
sharing that amazing view with us this
morning we appreciate it thank you
don't worry see you soon
okay see you bet
see you soon
serves up now the elusive yet beautiful
northern lights have been filmed
lighting up the canadian night sky look
at these pictures here we go witnessed
above the town of saint paul in alberta
the time lapse of the aurora borealis
was possible thanks to a solar storm
according to nasa the lights were formed
from clouds of solar plasma combining
with embedded magnetic fields which
released into space following a solar
eruption have you ever seen the northern
lights have you got some pictures maybe
send them to as we can share them with
our viewers um so that is in alberta in
canada how spectacular is that well the
northern lights
now it's world menopause day and for the
founder of menopause support it's all
about education and support she'll be
joining us next
[Music]
i think sadly along with you know other
black music artists um i've actually
received a bit of a pre-warning of the
damage that um uh racism in the music
industry can do to your mental health so
a lot of my black female music artists
friends have shared with me their
stories of being told that they can't do
certain genres uh that they have to
change their hair they have to change
the way that they talk um in order to
kind of get ahead in this industry um so
i've kind of positioned myself knowing
of the damage it can do to mental health
i position myself a little bit on the
outskirts of the music industry and even
still i've had experiences uh where
companies and and labels have made it
clear that there's only room for one
black artist on their roster or one
artist that does black music the
industry needs to work together we need
to collaborate all of us that's what
real diversity means we need
to look at
transparency in terms of earnings we've
already seen that
in the industry that
black music creators and industry
professionals earn less black women
specifically earn considerably less
we need to have that transparency and
understand what's going on we need to
give support at grassroots level and we
also need to give support in terms of
well-being people like leanne pinnock
obviously from little mix have spoken
out and keisha from uh the sugar babes
and also alexandra burke so i do think
there's an attention on this issue right
now which is great i just do think um as
roger said that there needs to be more
collaboration more transparency i think
our culture of not really talking about
music
kind of does us a disservice i i love to
talk about uh you know talk about money
and the what people are being paid in
the music industry
uh because i think that helps to um
avoid uh pay disparity as well and
hopefully having a body in any other
industry you'd have kind of a hr body
that you could go to
and i think black lives and music is
perfectly set up for this role to be
able to hold leaders to account and to
get everyone together to collaborate to
make the music industry more fair
we're seeing um artists who
start at the top and work their way very
quickly down to the bottom
with without the support of the industry
so we must work together we must
collaborate and give support so that
there's a level playing field for
everyone regardless of their color
[Music]
[Applause]
did you know that reducing pollution
outside of school can help stop toxic
air getting trapped in our
classrooms most places will have a grey
and misty start to sunday with outbreaks
of rain mainly in the north brighter
skies will develop in parts of the south
through the afternoon and it will feel
quite warm
the rain in the north should ease later
on in the day
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from one being low to 10 being
very high
brisk winds and outbreaks of rain for
some will maintain low levels of air
pollution on sunday
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
today marks world menopause day and
national campaign
make menopause mata is also dedicated to
educating people about the menopause and
was successful in getting it added to
the english curriculum
last year joining us now is the founder
of the campaign and menopause support uh
diane doesn't bring hello to diane
thanks for joining us tell us about your
experience of the menopause
morning kay um yeah my experience of the
menopause was pretty debilitating um i
had a surgical menopause which is where
the for me it was ovaries women cervix
were removed um but having my ovaries
removed put me into what's called a
surgical menopause at 45 and
unfortunately
nobody sat me down prior to the surgery
or in fact after it and described just
how debilitating a surgical menopause
could be
um that took me to a very dark place in
my life
where i came very close to ending my
life um i was incredibly fortunate to
have amazing family around me who got me
the help that i needed at crisis point
um however once i started to feel a
little bit like myself again i started
to wonder if i'd just been incredibly
unlucky or if there were other people
who were struggling the way that i had
and searching made me realize that i had
opened a pandora's box
and made me realize that actually i had
to do something to change it for the
future
what's your advice to women who are
going through the menopause because of
course it affects different women in
different ways
yeah absolutely so one in four will have
almost no symptoms at all three out of
four will have symptoms and one in four
will describe their symptoms as
debilitating so my advice would be
before menopause comes along educate
yourself
learn as much as you can about it
understand what the potential symptoms
could potentially be
and also
what the management of those symptoms
could be so that you understand how you
can help yourself of course that's all
very well but for most of us
we have to get that help via perhaps our
gp
and currently in the uk
not all gps have factual up-to-date
evidence-based information about
menopause and treatments so very often
menopause symptoms particularly the
psychological and cognitive symptoms
are misdiagnosed as anxiety and
depression and women are offered
antidepressants um so it's really
important that we educate gps we educate
the public so that's the reason that i
started the campaign back in 2018
is to have mandatory training for all
gps to have guidance and support in
every workplace and as you mentioned
education in schools and it's absolutely
vital it's a win-win situation both for
women
those who know and love women and also
for those who deliver health education
and it would save an absolute fortune
for the nhs too and for that yeah diane
and for those who employ women as well
of course it's good to talk to you
thanks so much indeed for joining us on
the program thank you pleasure thank you
thank you now questions have been raised
over how to protect mps after the
killing of sir david amos with
suggestions plainclothes officers or
private security could be brought in to
ensure their security stephen roberts is
joining us former deputy assistant
commissioner at the met hello she thanks
for joining us
what more can police do to protect mps
there's a whole scale of precautions
that could be taken but i think the
first point is each mp's protection
needs to be tailored to that mp
to the sort of activities that they're
undertaking when they're doing it where
they're doing it and indeed what that
particular mp is prepared to accept i i
heard uh dominique
on your program a few moments ago
saying that he would be very unhappy
with having
police officers outside a surgery that
he was running so there's going to be a
period of negotiation and proportionate
protection for each particular np
circumstances
but what about those mps that do want
support and also potentially those that
think they don't need it like i'm sure
sir david didn't feel that he needed it
and yet um he's we now he's now left you
know
he's left his widow and five daughters
well it's got to be at the end of the
day the mp themselves who agrees to the
protection uh
frankly on even on a practical scale
it's almost impossible to protect
somebody who doesn't want to be
protected but i'm sure that a
negotiation process could could get us
through that
uh and then it's a matter of there's a
scale of precautions we can start with
basically uh an appointment system to
see mps then those appointments those
people who've made appointments having
to have their identities verified
perhaps being done against intelligence
indices on those individuals and then
you're you're moving up towards physical
protection perhaps body searches knife
arches right up to the top end of the
scale but government ministers the prime
minister himself
would have a full protection
but it has to be tailored to each
individual mp and to what is sensible
and possible in in each set of
circumstances
yeah i suppose you know somebody
listening to that uh this morning who
might want to speak to their mp about
littering or
problems with one of the shops in town
or whatever if they think that their
background is going to be checked where
they live is going to be checked whether
they're on any sort of register is going
to be checked and then they're going to
have to go through an airport style
scanner and then potentially body
searched as well they're not going to do
it are they
no no and
this is part of the difficulty of
protecting the liberal democracy that we
all want to live in
and that's why i'm saying it has to be a
matter of negotiation and
ultimately it can only be provided if
the mps themselves are prepared to
accept it and you you've raised a number
of situations i can imagine situations
where somebody wants to complain about
having been victimized by the police in
themselves
and having a uniformed police officer or
knowing that there is a police officer
there would be a very off-putting
situation and
nobody would want that to be
in place no um
online hate has um according to uh the
deputy prime minister made politicians
more at risk now than they were 10 years
ago i'm guessing that you would concur
with that
oh the echo chamber of social media
can only do harm as far as i'm concerned
the idea that somebody can be
pushing hate speech towards any
individual not not just mps
but any individual
without even identifying themselves is
just
frankly absurd
um
and it needs to be rectified but equally
public discourse around politics needs
to change abuse from anonymous members
of the public is awful
but
we've seen only two recently abused from
other mps we have to learn to have
political debate with respect and that
that's a starting point that's a
cultural change that needs to happen and
that in itself
hopefully will will protect our
democracy and and our mps
stephen roberts former deputy assistant
commissioner at the metropolitan police
based in essex thank you very much
indeed for joining us thank you